[Music]
we've been talking a little bit about
Final Four right tonight and I don't
know were you is that something you ever
got excited about the lutely well I went
to Kansas so it's University of Kansas
Wow
how awkward for that one person in the
crowd who's being beaten out by everyone
else in the crowd it was you know I was
so rooting for him we had a really tough
loss obviously against Michigan but I
well that explains the lack of applause
then for Kansas but I was at Kansas when
they won the national championship well
you were there when they want and it's
the most exciting thing that can happen
to a school it's it's a blast yeah so I
love to follow but I never played I was
always a bad basketball player okay did
you get involved in the team in any way
you didn't play
I didn't play no I um I I when I was in
junior high I was the manager of our
basketball team you were the manager
yeah and that's why why did you do that
I wanted people to think I was on the
team and the best part of it was and
this was true this is such a sad
admission but when we would get off we
go to opposing schools we get off the
bus all the players and the manager and
the coach we all dress in coat and tie
and when I get off the bus the girls
from the other school would see us all
and I and I would think they would think
I was on the team just because you were
wearing a suit like everyone else and
then I broke my finger one time and and
I had to sit on the sidelines I wasn't
playing anyway but I was so excited
because then everyone would just think I
was injured because of a small small
small
I had a splint okay look like you know
NAT I can't I got to stay in the suit I
can't go out and play what about
football is football oh I loved okay
football was my favorite and I was a
huge Steelers fan as a kid and I see
what you're doing you're just mentioning
everything well I would definitely reach
every person in the crowd
I spent some time on the planet Earth a
guy down here booed earth he's from he's
the one with gills meant I was to a
Steelers game though and I was so
excited I got into the locker room I
mean literally mile I was about ten in
my life there's the locker room at ten I
think I the guy that was weird to work
with my dad I'm sure he somehow paid off
the guy right apparently the guy that
sounds already creepy that was a ten
year old going like a game of with this
guy my dad worked with but he was
somehow kind of new Bradshaw and then I
think talked his way into the locker
room and I was so excited to meet my
heroes truly my heroes and I'll never
forget walking into the locker room and
there they all were and they were all
naked and I didn't know how the story is
getting creepier and creepier I'll take
your son to the game to the locker room
I'll take an elite Bradshaw and he did I
met Terry Bradshaw and it was like mr.
Bradshaw me and he was so nice to me and
he was taking time to talk with me but
he was naked and I was also ten years
old I was like right at the height of
maybe you don't want to be you did a
weird me went mr. bradshawe it wasn't I
reached out yeah mr. Bradshaw
[Applause]
that's exactly
I followed everything we're talking
about now is super creepy but it was a
million there's Mean Joe green yeah and
then right and there's yeah yeah we
completely understand thanks for the
mime work